[Música]
hace cuatro años yo comencé una búsqueda
una misión
con una serie de aliados increíbles
gente que admiro y respeto muchísimo que
me han enseñado tanto esta búsqueda se
trató de identificar cómo podríamos
contribuir a la preservación y
restauración de los ecosistemas del
mundo y ahí descubrí que méxico es uno
de los actores más importantes en
materia de ecosistemas abajo del agua se
esconde el segundo arrecife más
importante del mundo el arrecife
mesoamericano en el caribe mexicano y
esta aventura me llevó a entender cosas
que después jamás me hubiera imaginado
yo sabía poco y nada realmente de los
corales así que les voy a compartir un
poco de qué se trata en realidad los
colores corales son estos son pólipos
que pueden ser desde el tamaño de una
aguja hasta un pie
estos generan unas estructuras de calcio
con las cuales se protegen de las cuales
pues básicamente se crean las playas y
se van acumulando y acumulando durante
siglos y siglos y siglos de evolución
quiero que conozcan algunos de esos
nuestros primeros ancestros así como los
ven son una especie de transición de
vida de mineral animal y ahí se
desprenden un montón de criaturas que yo
jamás me imaginé que fuera esto posible
venimos del mar
los seres humanos toda la naturaleza
viene del océano y ellos son el mapa
para entender este origen las noches de
luna llena
se aparean
son animales hay machos hay hembras y en
la luna llena sueltan esperma y óvulos y
ahí cuando se tocan después de un
milagro de ecuación científica se posan
en alguna roca en algún lugar tal vez en
algún otro coral y a partir de eso
empiezan a desarrollarse
estos pólipos también a veces se usan
para pelearse entre sí que tienen una
actividad importantísima sin embargo
nosotros lo que vemos principalmente son
fotografías en donde los pececitos están
alrededor de ellos
unos cuantos pececitos calculando así de
lo que tenemos descubiertos son 2.5
millones sostienen el 25 por ciento de
toda la vida marina es la base de todo
un ecosistema aunque lo queremos ver
como una especie en realidad no lo es
hay muchas especies que están conectadas
interconectadas que se comunican y de
las cuales el plato que llega a la mesa
se alimenta también
estos corales también sirven como la
barrera natural para las tormentas y los
huracanes
durante siglos y siglos de evolución
generaron estas estructuras y es lo que
mantiene con tanta calma y también
protege a todo este caribe todo este
ecuador porque es donde principalmente
se reúnen los corales quiero que
entendamos que son menos del 1% del
océano que pues es tres cuartas partes
del mundo del océano es lo que tiene
coral y sabíamos poco y nada hasta hace
poco
porque es importante porque es
importante que entendamos qué es lo que
está pasando allá abajo y el gran reto
que es para todos los seres humanos
realmente ser empáticos con algo que no
vemos
hemos escuchado sobre especies
específicamente vamos a poner el caso de
la vaquita marina pero esta es una
especie ésta sostiene 2.5 millones
estamos hablando de que si estas
especies se extinguen vamos a tener un
efecto de cascada de pérdida de
especímenes que jamás se ha visto en la
historia de la humanidad no sabemos cómo
reaccionar ante ello es por eso que este
año las naciones unidas han generado el
tema del año internacional del arrecife
2018 la misión de los objetivos
desarrollo sustentable es concientizar a
la población sobre el valor de los
ecosistemas marinos como les comentaba
se acentúa con cambio climático todo
este efecto de tormentas de huracanes en
categoría 5 y en repeticiones que nunca
antes lo habíamos visto
y no y finalmente pues este era la gran
barrera o sea estos estos corales
especialmente los que son tipos de alce
son los colores hermosos con una
capacidad de crecer increíble son los
que amortiguan la fuerza del océano la
fuerza de los huracanes y también
pues el valor de todas las playas se ve
afectado porque se empiezan a deteriorar
las mismas playas están hechas de coral
muerto es el polvo de la arena lo que
vemos en las playas es el coral es la
estructura de carbono
qué pasaría si este 25% de la vida
marina empieza a
pues a desaparecer no creo que todos
entendemos que el efecto por ejemplo en
los que todavía comemos carne que yo
estoy en proceso quiero confesarlo
porque ya entendí y me estoy
transformando también y es un proceso y
echémosle ganas todos porque todos
debemos ver
[Aplausos]
estuve con la doctora silvia el que es
una de las personas que yo creo que
merece más la admiración del mundo en
este momento les aconsejo que sigan su
trabajo es una verdadera heroína y
estábamos en un pleno foro océanos y lo
único que servían era era pescado era
marisco y el evento era digamos pro
pesca no sustentable y todo pero seamos
sinceros o sea el paso en el que estamos
consumiendo sushi cuanta cosa ya es
brutal no le estamos dando tiempo al
océano de recuperarse qué es lo que está
pasando se llama el holocausto marino
así de fuerte y sabemos poco y nada de
este tema y como mexicanos de pronto nos
topamos con que menos
el 70%
del oxígeno del mundo se produce en el
océano
no en los bosques de la amazonía no en
los bosques de lacandona que también nos
llevábamos acabe con ganas sino en el
océano además
el dióxido de carbono el fenómeno de
cambio climático se contiene en el
océano y esto está haciendo que el coral
se blanquee está haciendo que se estresa
y está en lo que se muera la mitad de
los corales en australia en la gran
barrera de coral se fue y aquí en méxico
estamos en cifras también del 50 y 70
por ciento pérdida de densidad no hemos
llegado todavía las temperaturas que lo
blanquean pero es posible que estemos
ahí y se aparte les digo que estos
pequeños ancestros se encargan de
contener el efecto de invernadero pues
realmente estamos hablando de que no es
nada más el tema del pescado es también
el supply de oxígeno y la amortiguación
del carbono es tremendamente importante
y vital su participación pero a mí lo
que más me enganchó fue esto
entender que un billón de personas
dependen directamente de los arrecifes
de coral como fuente de proteínas porque
no saben otra cosa tal vez pero lo es
estamos hablando que un billón de
personas va a sufrir hambre va a perder
trabajos y va a tener que emigrar va a
tener un sufrimiento que normalmente le
toca siempre a la gente con menos
recursos y es por ellos que tenemos que
tomar acción todos nosotros nuestro
proyecto ha generado
pues algunos elementos de innovación
porque porque realmente yo no soy
biólogo yo hace 4 años no tenía el
conocimiento que tengo ahora con
respecto a los corales pero tengo el
honor de decir que trabajo con los
mejores biólogos no nada más de méxico
sino de diferentes partes del mundo
izquierdo que nosotros que queríamos
hacer aportar y desde dónde podía
aportar desde innovación social desde
tecnologías emergentes como realidad
virtual block change big data
hicimos campañas de arte también para
utilizar el arte como un activador de la
conciencia social
cuando vean los visores de realidad
virtual vean los como una herramienta de
empatía vean los como una herramienta de
educación porque estos niños de escuelas
rurales mayas no tienen el dinero de
acceder a comprarse un teléfono de estos
pero que la primera vez que se acercan a
un contenido de este tecnología tan
disruptiva que sea de medio ambiente los
inspira los inspira y era así inspirador
todos haciendo cola cuando era un caos
cuando llegamos de pronto vieron esto
dijeron yo quiero aprender y con ellos
se llevaron la información la emoción a
sus casas y hablaron con sus padres y
nos ganamos la legitimidad y el apoyo de
las comunidades locales y con ese apoyo
de las comunidades locales hemos hecho
un montón de cosas
este señor se llama josé luís torres no
buceaba pero es un artista urbano pero
yo a bucear se enamoró del tema y hasta
el día de hoy no ha parado lleva 70
murales desde el caribe hasta el
pacífico mexicano y es una de las
campañas de arte urbano más importantes
que ha dado la nación y es totalmente
hecha por convicción de las personas
esta es la granja de corales que tenemos
en consume la queremos granjas de
corales en todo méxico en todo el caribe
en todos los lugares porque también nos
permiten ofrecer una solución en base al
mercado en la que transformamos al
turismo en la fuerza de restauración son
15 millones de turistas los que
atraviesan el caribe mexicano
por números estamos en desventaja a los
pocos que nos queremos dedicar a esto
pero si los usamos para que nos ayuden y
yo creo que todos los turistas del mundo
van a querer participar en algo tan
hermoso como salvar los ecosistemas
y poder suave para el cambio social el
efecto dominó hablamos de un botón coral
hicimos una propuesta en las elecciones
en la cual comprometimos al gobernador a
que si ganaba iba a plantar una colonia
de 24 corales por cada voto recibido y
así fue como sucedió y al día de hoy se
creó todo un tren político que no ha
parado y los políticos todos quieren un
highlight están planteando corales así
que brabo por esa actitud yo no los voy
a juzgar
también gracias vinculación estratégica
y cerca de gente mucho más preparada que
nosotros y mucho más capaz que nosotros
aquí está en la misma mesa el maestro
marcel julian medina mora quien se
encarga de toda la herramienta de big
data con la cual monitoreamos todas las
tendencias y todas las cosas relevantes
con respecto al coral y gracias a eso
tenemos información para tomar
decisiones y manuel gutiérrez noveló
quien ha sido un gran gran pues como
decirle patrono o padrino o amigo para
el proyecto y él es el inventor mexicano
con más patentes en la historia vale es
uno de los grandes científicos y que
deberíamos todos de conocerlo nos ha
apoyado muchísimo ahí estábamos con la
senadora a vélez time y logramos crear
un punto de acuerdo en el que el
congreso exhorta a la secretaría de
marina- a fortalecer las acciones a
favor de restaurar los arrecifes todo
este tipo de cosas nos ha llevado hasta
las naciones unidas a donde pues ya nos
reconocieron por ser un caso de
implementación de estas diferentes
tecnologías lo que nosotros queremos
proponer es implementar diseño
regenerativo y poner a la tecnología a
favor del ser humano y de la naturaleza
lo que nosotros proponemos qué es lo que
quisiéramos hacer declarar los
ecosistemas como un derecho de la
humanidad o sea no es nada más de los
mexicanos no de nada más entonces no es
un problema aislado el océano la
biodiversidad los ecosistemas no tienen
fronteras esa es una cosa que nos
inventamos nosotros por lo tanto tenemos
que actuar lo en conjunto para
resolverlo en conjunto solamente así
podemos enfrentarlo crear un consejo de
sabios que los ciudadanos le entreguen
la confianza a gente especializada que
está legitimizada que no es una
burocracia este tema de la restauración
porque allí es donde siempre ha estado
el problema se ha tardado científicos
han hablado de esto desde el año 2000
desde el año 2000 ya sabían los hombres
más poderosos del mundo que esto iba a
pasar en un escenario 2050 que ahora se
ha cortado el 2030 y nosotros ni
enterados y eso se me hace aberrante
una acción global
acciones separadas en diferente tiempo
nunca van a ser tan importantes como una
acción colectiva y realmente no nos
podemos hacer ya tontos con el tema de
las emisiones de so2 así el día de hoy
pararán completamente tenemos 568 años
para recuperarnos de esto el escenario
es dramático y por supuesto resaltar
empoderar y financiar todas las
soluciones globales que están en la mesa
al día de hoy en montón y darle a los
científicos la oportunidad de generar
innovación con investigación y
desarrollo para que después podamos
implementar esta esta ciencia y crear
tecnología sustentable hay un futuro
nuevo que podemos crear en conjunto en
el cual el hombre y la naturaleza
convergen
y así me gustaría ver a mi el planeta
tierra a olvidarnos del problema de que
estamos sobre poblando y si empezara a
colonizar también en el océano pero no
como lo hemos hecho hasta el día de hoy
el día de hoy somos la generación que va
a pasar a la historia como la que perdió
los ecosistemas o va a hacer algo para
resolverlo para rescatarlos y como ya
están informados los hago responsables
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]